[Music]
good morning good afternoon good evening
everyone welcome back to GameSpot's best
of 2017 countdown today it is finally
time December 20th to do our mega stream
counting down from our third game to our
2nd to our overall game of the year as
voted and argued on by the GameSpot
staff we very much might as well get
right into it as I'm sure all of you
think you know what this game is so
here's a montage for our number 3 game
of 2017
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there you have it super mario odyssey
from nintendo is our number three game
of 2017 I'm Mike my Hardy here to chat
about it with Peter Brown hello again
Randolph Ramsey hello everybody and
Justin hey Walt
hey hey you both like to game a lot so I
figured you bring him up bring you on
you didn't bring me on but you like this
game a lot we we all argued over this
and the number two game cuz it was kind
of a we knew what the top three were but
we had to deliberate on wit to decide to
give it to you you kind of almost spoil
the game right that's why that's why I
covered up my sweater before the stream
but here it is now this is completely
coincidental by the way my wife bought
me this she didn't decide a number three
mmm
blame your wife but I the T Rexes are in
Mario as well Jeff and I just like
dinosaurs I I was not intentionally buff
Santa's not in it so I can't be blamed
for it but Santa's in Star Wars but
anyway Super Mario Odyssey who obviously
the next in the long-running series of
one of the most iconic characters in
video games specifically one of the 3d
platformers what does this game do
Justin that kind of pushed the 3d Mario
or the 3d platformers like evolved it so
to speak I this was a really hard
decision to make especially in a year
like 2017 and you would think like a
traditional platformer it's not gonna
live up and like I thought is well that
like Mario's gonna be in the top ten but
getting as high as it did for number
three the thing that I think really
catapulted is both the new mechanics
that introduced like those are it's
really fun to take control of other
characters to use the Hat and kind of a
really not necessarily innovative but a
really different way for a Mario game
but also that then it just encapsulates
fun like it is it is joy in a in a disc
encapsulate it's fun and it puts you in
a girl and you yeah but yeah puns are
already rolling we're watching b-roll of
a new dog city right here Randy but all
the different kingdoms you go to are
kind of this is the first time you see
real people or whatever that you would
assume are real billions and there's a
lot of weird stuff going on in this game
but how do those mechanics kind of
coalesce to actually make the gameplay
and the world design feel like you know
like you're collecting power moons and
usually it's like stars or shines or
what have you but you collecting power
moves in this and you were talking
earlier before we run live about how
it's more of a steady stream of them
rather than like one that takes a while
to get and then you go to the next one
it's kind of the stream of like dopamine
releases yeah yeah I think in terms of
like game design they've made a lot of
sort of moves to make it more accessible
to on the go play which the switch is
excellent at and yeah as you said you
know moons and this is like what eight
hundred more than eight hundred moons in
the game already three I think yeah so
you're only ever like one or two minutes
away from actually finding something and
then the world is designed you know all
the different sort of like kingdoms are
designed in such a way that you know
like anywhere that you look if you go in
that direction you'll probably find
something that is interesting or a moon
that you can achieve I played this game
I think the bulk of this game I play
while I was on the bus you know to and
from work and it always felt like I was
actually achieving something that I'd
made a lot of progress every time I
actually touch this game it's almost
like a mobile like experience exactly
yeah yeah yeah pee-yew reviewed this
gave it one of the three ten out of tens
a game spot which means it's essential
mm-hmm what was it about the what makes
this game essential you were talking
about how like the difficulty because
the game much of the platforming isn't
difficult in itself until you get to
later stages you were saying it's
difficult in a different way kind of the
way it forces you to encourage you to
look at the world yeah as Randy was
saying you know let you know pick a
direction go there you'll find something
but you you slowly learned that there
are you know certain rules at play and
manipulating the camera in such a way
can can help you look at the world
differently and it's and it's a lot
about deciding like what your
surroundings are and what you're capable
of achieving you know with Mario's
skills and sometimes you know obviously
using capital look beyond Mario skills
and see how the enemies in the
environment help it's not difficult in
that it's challenging it's difficult in
that it challenges you if that makes
sense yeah Justin like we're kind of
we're looking at a toast arena town in
the desert Kingdom or I mean this is the
desert Kingdom toast arena towns off to
the left somewhere but one thing this
game does also it like gives you these
sand boxes rather than these discrete
levels obviously in older Mario's
oftentimes there were open world aspects
or at least small sandbox open world
aspect
this very much encouraged you to just go
explore and that kind of ties into the
fact that you can find power moons left
and right it anywhere you want how did
you feel that the sandbox design of the
worlds contributed to the overall
experience like like Randy said it's
just it's a lot of fun it just keeps
pulling you along like I think other
Mario games it felt like you would go
into a level and you have a distinct
star that you're going for and maybe
there's some other side things that
you'd go along but here it's like it's a
sense of discovery everything that you
find you're like yeah as you're going
along around here's what I think I'm
gonna do and then you get pulled on you
said well I see something else with me
let me try to go do that really quickly
and like it just adds to that I'm gonna
keep playing like I'm just one more like
that I guess a Pringles type feel like
like it I can't stop I want to keep keep
grabbing more moons
yeah the also the variety of activity
that you're doing I mean like the
variety is in itself is sometimes you
just a buzzword just described game is
being fun but this one like I mean you
can you throw your cap at like a
pterodactyl to start gliding around but
then in like five minutes later you're
doing this infuriating minigame where
the guy shows you the steps you're
supposed to take the pattern and then
they disappear for also you have to kind
of it was no no it was really I thought
it was fun but I sucked at it the circle
one in the desert it took me like six
tries and I literally had to start
walking then just keep the analog stick
at that certain angle but did you find
that the variety of quests or missions
or just power moon challenges were kind
of enough to keep you going from one of
the next Randi I did yeah and I think
one of the sort of the the best things
about this too is you can play this game
in a variety of different ways and I
think accessibility is one of the key
things in this thing right but I think
this game in some quarters has been
criticized for being a little bit too
safe with the Mario formula right like
it didn't actually push you know what
Mario is capable of in the same way that
other games you know push their genres
but but I think you know in the ways
that it did push they're really smart
ways you know just having you know no
lives for example in this one is it is
like a critical change to to how Mario
does things you know Cappy and you know
the ability to to have it was like a few
dozen different forms you know
throughout the game being able to buy
moons you know I think it's such an
interesting way to try and you know
make you keep up with other people whose
skill levels may be higher than yours if
you want to see more of the endgame or
or delay the stages you don't
necessarily have to go and get all the
moons and you know in each of the world
you can just buy your way through it it
does like so many new interesting things
that makes it I think you know the most
accessible Mario's ever been it's really
interesting as well that it doesn't
unlock new abilities like you go to all
these new worlds you have the same skill
set from the very beginning of the game
the things you're buying are completely
cosmetic but you still you're kind of
driven along like no I want to unlock
this new silly costume or put together a
new combination but no matter what from
the beginning of the game to the end of
the game you have the same skill set
yeah then also the economy kind of
actually it does put you through the
game but like also in terms of the world
design I feel like well without spoiling
anything P like there the story does do
different things here that's not usually
the main focus of a 3d Mario game it's
kind of one of the most rote narratives
and games I would say this does do
different things with it however minor
or they might be are they even minors
everything well it doesn't make a big
deal about it yeah but it but it
certainly plays with your expectations a
little bit and that's you know that's
when the story is complete but then like
the game opens up to be even broader so
the story again is really not the focus
but it does just sort of remind you that
hey things are a little bit different
now and the way that they do sort of
tinker with your expectations of the
narrative pays off even though it's not
like a a major change I mean well
depending how you look at it yeah again
we don't want spoil it we're gonna be
streaming in a few minutes the game
itself and we might spoil it then but in
general Justin what was the what's the
number one thing that stuck with you
about Mario ever since it's what October
27th release you know you play a lot of
Mario games especially like 3d Mario
games what was it that made this
something you want to argue for I in
2017 there's been there so many amazing
games like I I think this is like one of
the hardest game leader discussions
we've had in in almost 10 years but
Mario stood out just because it it
really does capture the essence of fun
like it is just fun in in the perfect
way it's like Nintendo nails that with
their video games and
I'll are you I think can sometimes be a
little formulaic but this one it just
felt like the right game at the right
time to just sit back and enjoy the ride
it was an action-adventure fun movie and
maybe it won't be something that that
resonates for you know 20 years down the
line but I think no matter what like
capturing that essence of fun is such
such a Nintendo thing and something that
was just so needed in 2017 for me I
always bring like the angle I bring into
our games poet game of the year
discussions is always the old man
dad vote yeah and for me like you
mentioned it may not you know have that
resonance in twenty years I actually
think it might because you know like I
played this with my with my
eight-year-old son and he he essentially
played this entire game solo I tried to
help him you know as much as I could but
he managed to like actually get to the
end defeat the final boss and now he's
going through all the extra challenges
like all on his own and it was only
until halfway through that he realized
he could actually turn a system of it on
so you know in terms of you know impact
on you know someone who's younger like
you know I think this is this generation
Super Mario 64 right like this is the
game that you know my son will remember
in 20 years time as the game that got up
into Mario and it's only like a much
stronger argument for the Nintendo
switch as if it needed any more this
year it's almost like another case for
in Tendo making a huge comeback in 2017
it's crazy where the switch is that
right now I think we all saw Zelda and
Mario coming and we knew that there were
other games arriving but it's just it's
crazy to look back now or at least just
look at my switch main you and be like
wow like there are more games I want to
play this second on my switch than on
any other platform you even told me that
a Nintendo platform would be my
preferred console of 2017 I probably
would not believe you a year ago believe
it yeah now it makes sense
anyway Super Mario Odyssey is GameSpot's
number three game of 2017 if you're
watching this on youtube or GameSpot
after we talked about it live go catch
up on the rest of our game of the year
we went near automata what remains be to
finch hell-blade Senna was sacrifice
Wolfenstein to the new order horizon
zero dawn divinity original sin - and
resen evil 7 we have not announced the
next two yet we will do that shortly if
you're watching this live but
go catch up on that